construit en 1530 propriété aujourd'hui
de la famille michaud le château de
l'isle est et ses jardins sont un havre
de paix entre eux azay le rideau au
seuil et plus exactement sur les deux
communes en même temps son histoire a
été marquée par les séjours de deux
sculpteurs d'exception auguste rodin et
camille claudel
ce fut un lieu de création pour les deux
génies vers 1890 et pas seulement
je pense que camille claudel et rodin
ont vécu des amours tumultueuses dans
cette propriété notamment dans cette
pièce qui était peut-être leur chambre
puisque selon une lettre de mademoiselle
vayssié une amie camille celle-ci lui
écrit ces mots j'ai rêvé de vous cette
nuit que vous des sentiers de votre tour
avec votre ombrelle rouge et que vous
mettiez le feu c'est la forêt alentour
alors évidemment salem dire c'est
incroyable ces essais les reps de
toujours un peu fou et bien oui mais
elle nous renseigne sur un détail
il dormait dans une tour or à lille est
il n'y en a que deux
si je pouvais est une modeste présence à
nos côtés
le film qui sort aujourd'hui au cinéma a
été tourné en partie à lille est
c'était en mai 2016 ça coïncide
aujourd'hui avec le centenaire de la
mort du sculpteur un éclairage qui
pourrait bénéficier au château de l'isle
est et à sa fréquentation
c'est légitime que je rêve que lille est
grâce à ce film apparaissent beaucoup
plus dans les médias
aux yeux du public afin qu'ils puissent
venir le découvrir parce que je pense
que effectivement les tourancheau qui
sont les premiers concernés ne
connaissent pas encore lille est ou du
moins très peu pour sa cinquième saison
d'ouverture au public de mai à septembre
le château espère continuer sa phase
ascendante
l'an passé il a accueilli trente mille
visiteurs